je suis financière je travaille dans la
finance
et quand je commence à expliquer ce que
je fais dans la vie les gens en général
s'imagine ça ou bien ça et même parfois
ça cela ne me ressemble pas vraiment
d'abord peut-être parce que je suis une
femme et que l'univers de la finance est
réputé très masculin mais aussi sûrement
parce que je ne suis pas obsédé par les
profits la rentabilité ou la cocaïne
bref vous voyez ce que je veux dire
maintenant quand on me demande ce que je
fais dans la vie je réponds que je
travaille dans le développement durable
sauf que du coup on général les gens
s'imaginent ça ou bien ça et même
parfois ça oui
cela ne me ressemble pas vraiment non
plus non pas que je n'aime pas les
retraitants vannes le look des nanas des
années 70
cultiver des légumes dans mon potager
ainsi que d'autres débats tout ça pour
vous dire que pendant longtemps j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à trouver l'équilibré
entre mon métier dans la finance et des
aspirations personnelles entre les
sujets économiques qui me passionne et
les enjeux environnementaux et sociaux
qui s'impose à nous et nous oblige à
repenser complètement notre économie et
puis vous devez certainement vous
demandez quel peut bien être le lien
entre la finance et le développement
durable
espérons que ce ne soit pas une
opération de greenwashing pas vrai en
effet c'est à première vue assez
antinomique
j'en conviens mais laissez moi vous en
dire un peu plus
ce que je vous montre à l'écran c'est ma
vie en 2013 c'est la vie que j'avais
deux fils mon premier bureau à la
défense c'est sympa non après réflexion
je crois qu'il jolie vue et une bonne
rémunération sont une super excuse pour
justifier un job qui peut parfois
manquer de sens à l'époque je commençait
tout juste à prendre conscience de la
gravité du changement climatique
bien sûr comme tous ceux de ma
génération j'avais grandi avec le
discours de jacques chirac
notre maison brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs effectivement j'avais détourner
le regard pendant très longtemps je
trouvais les discours plutôt alarmistes
voire même oppressant et j'avais préféré
recentrer mon attention sur des réalités
court terme faire de bonnes études et un
travail et je me retrouvais donc là à
rêvasser en regardant par la fenêtre
quand on n'aime pas spécialement ce
qu'on fait on est en général loin d'être
le meilleur
j'ai donc changé de job pour un autre
toujours dans la finance et au bout de
six mois à la fin de ma période
d'apprentissage et de montée en
compétence
la tendance est tombé chemin il y est
toujours à mourir et mon errance a
continué j'ai visité comme ça cinq six
sept tours de la défense en quelques
années je vous épargne les photos de la
vue on finit même par s'en lasser
comme le disait si bien sénèque
il n'ya point de vent favorable pour
celui qui ne sait pas vers où il va mais
chaque changement de job
ma réflexion safin et la vision que
j'avais de la finance se précisait
certaines questions massalia quelle part
de mon activité finance bien l'économie
réelle
comment la finance pourrait-elle devenir
le moteur de la transition écologique et
sociale quels mécanismes macro
économiques et réglementaires peuvent
répondre à l'équation du changement
climatique
et pourquoi alors que j'ai contrôlé des
opérations spéculatives qui se chiffre
en milliards en milliards toute la
journée
y at il encore des sans abri dans ce
quartier d'affaires le monde de la
finance classique n'apprécie pas
forcément les gens qui posent trop de
questions et les gens qui se posent trop
de questions dont certaines n'ont pas
vocation à rester employés des banques
pour le bien de tous donc mes anciens
employeurs que je salue j'ai donc tirer
ma révérence
nous sommes en 2016 je sais exactement
ce que je veux faire dans la vie j'ai vu
des dizaines de livres sur le
financement de la transition écologique
j'ai rédigé mon mémoire de fin d'étude
sur le sujet j'ai regardé des centaines
peut être des milliers de documentaires
et de conférences et j'ai acquis une
certitude les financiers dès lors qu'ils
savent identifier les entreprises les
plus vertueuses peuvent alors les
encourager à progresser et à contrario
obligé celles qui ne rentre pas dans le
rang à se transformer pour répondre aux
enjeux
alors concrètement comment on fait et
bien tout d'abord en plus de l'analyse
financière classique on étudie les
entreprises dans lesquelles nous
souhaitons investir au travers de
nouveaux critères
ce sont des indicateurs environnementaux
sociaux et de gouvernance
les critères e sg ce sont ces
indicateurs qui nous permettent de
savoir au delà des comptes de résultats
et des bilans si une entreprise a de
beaux jours devant elle ou bien si elle
est menacée
nous analysons des centaines
d'indicateurs comme par exemple les
émissions de co2 des entreprises
le climat social en interne les
pratiques en matière de lutte contre la
corruption mais aussi les efforts pour
rendre les produits plus durables ou
encore les différences de rémunérations
entre le salaire le plus bas et celui le
plus haut
une fois cette analyse effectuée deux
choix s'offrent à nous ne pas investir
dans une entreprise ou même tout un
secteur
si cette analyse nous montre que qu'il
existe un risque de perte à court moyen
ou long terme ou bien au contraire
investir et faire usage de notre pouvoir
d'actionnaire pour pousser l'entreprise
à se transformer c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'engagement actionnaires
et c'est donc ça la finance responsable
c'est comme ça que l'on marie la finance
et le développement durable finance
responsable
c'est une finance qui s'adapte aux
limites du capitalisme qui se remet au
service d'une économie humaine et
citoyenne
c'est une finance riche de sens qui
renvoie soit il est une évidence aucun
meilleur ne sera possible sans un
retournement radical de nos façons
d'appréhender l'économie c'est pratique
se développe et elles deviendront
bientôt la norme
elles permettent la création de nouveaux
métiers le directeur rse par exemple qui
a pour objectif d'accompagner les
dirigeants d'entreprises dans la
transition écologique et sociale
l'analyse de sg qui étudie les
entreprises par le prisme de ces
nouveaux indicateurs mais aussi le
gestionnaire des risques climatiques qui
mesure l'impact du changement climatique
sur la valorisation des entreprises et
donc sur la stabilité du système
financier la perspective de ces nouveaux
métiers et l'impact positif que l'on
peut peut-être avoir sur l'économie
c'est ce qui m'a porté durant les quatre
années qui ont suivi j'ai été
consultante
j'ai accompagné des entreprises des
institutions financières j'ai enfilé la
casquette de directrice de développement
durable pour le cabinet dans lequel je
travaillais j'ai rencontré des
entrepreneurs incroyable j'ai soutenu
des projets associatifs
j'ai commencé à enseigner aussi
transmettre tout ce que j'avais appris
dans les livres et dans la vie à
l'époque où j'avais commencé à
m'intéresser à ces sujets il n'y avait
pas encore de cadre universitaire tout
était donc à inventer et wau pour la
première fois pour la toute première
fois de ma vie je ne me suis pas ennuyé
pendant une seule seconde
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai plus fort
me regarder par la fenêtre
les vues du 30e et sages sont loin
maintenant et j'ai acquis une certitude
certes
on est très rarement le meilleur quand
on fait quelque chose que l'on n'aime
pas mais l' inverse et vérifiable on
n'est jamais plus productif que lorsque
l'on fait ce que l'on aime
on a tous une vocation un truc qui nous
donne envie de rester éveillé jusqu'au
bout de la nuit
le système scolaire et les entreprises
devraient nous pousser dans cette quête
nous aider à trouver notre juste place
car pour des questions d'épanouissement
individuel tout comme pour des questions
de productivité collective c'est la
façon la plus efficiente d'agir
qui suis-je alors je suis une financière
responsable
voilà ce que je fais vraiment dans la
vie mon métier consiste à encourager les
pratiques financières durable celle qui
redonne à l'argent son véritable rôle
celle qui finance les projets d'avenir
celles qui construisent le monde de
demain
un monde que j'imagine meilleur
qu'aujourd'hui je suis aussi financière
consciente
consciente de l'impact terrible que peux
avoir ma profession sur les écosystèmes
et l'humain consciente que nous n'avons
pas su tirer le meilleur de nous mêmes
et que l'appât du gain a pu faire perdre
la raison de certains de mes confrères
je m'excuse en leur nom je ne vais pas
vous le cacher nous financiers nous
sommes parfois vraiment planté
nous avons perdu pied nous avons bafouée
certaines valeurs élémentaires
nous avons été à l'origine des pires
crises celle qui met d économie à genoux
celles qui détruisent des emplois et
enrichissent les plus véreux mais nous
pourrions aussi être à l'origine des
meilleurs revirement notre profession
nous donne un pouvoir incroyable nous
permet de changer réellement les choses
vous le devinez sûrement je suis une
grande optimiste je crois en l'humain
comme certains os x en leur dieu je suis
intimement convaincu qu'une fois que
nous trouvons la force de dépasser nos
peurs nos doutes notre culpabilité ou
notre m
pour passer à l'action l'espoir est
partout et que cet espoir
nous devons le mettre au service du bien
commun à mes amis financiers
bien sûr que le changement fait peur
bien sûr qu'il y a tout à réinventer
mais n'est-ce pas merveilleux
n'est ce pas une formidable opportunité
de montrer au monde de quoi nous sommes
capables
n'est ce pas une incroyable occasion de
redonner à notre métier ses lettres de
noblesse à mes amis du développement
durable bien sûr que le monde est à
genoux bien sûr que l'avenir est
effrayant et que le constat scientifique
est accablant bien sûr que nous sommes
tous responsables et qu'il ya encore
bien trop de personnes mal informées ou
qui ne voit les choses qu'à court terme
mais pensez vous vraiment que le
désarroi et le repli sur soi vous
aideront à surmonter les épreuves qui
nous attendent
ni le déni ni la colère ni la haine ni
le désespoir ne seront de bonnes armes
face à ces combats nous sommes la
dernière génération à pouvoir changer
les choses alors agissons en conséquence
agissant avec optimisme et espoir et
puis sincèrement même si on se plante
pour ma part je serais heureux d'y avoir
cru heureuse d'avoir au moins essayer je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons remettre
l'argent au service du bien commun
je suis persuadé que nous pouvons
ensemble changer pour le meilleur
l'heure du changement a sonné l'heure de
remettre la finance au service de
l'humain est arrivé bien entendu pour
mener à bien cette mission
nous ne pouvons pas agir uniquement de
façon individuelle mais j'ai une bonne
nouvelle des finances est conscient des
finances et responsable
il y en a déjà beaucoup évidemment je
vous présente l'association les acteurs
de la finance responsable d
à plus de 130 individus déjà plus de 130
bonnes âmes au service d'un avenir
meilleur
je suis ravi de pouvoir vous présenter
olivia experte dans les sujets
réglementaires liées à la finance
yvan ancien directeur financier d'apple
france à celle directeur commercial
d'une société spécialisée dans la mesure
de l'impact des entreprises véronique
consultante experte dans les sujets de
la rse patricia ancienne directrice
d'une succursale d'un groupe bancaire
spécialisé dans le financement de la
transition écologique
je vais être maël lucas gestionnaire de
patrimoine prêts à vous guider pour que
vos placements apporte au delà de leur
rendement du centre et utilité sociale
dans le monde de demain
je suis ravie vraiment de pouvoir vous
dire que la finance a les moyens de
changer les choses de vous dire que vous
pourrez demain nous faire confiance de
vous affirmer que nous financier
conscient ferons notre possible pour que
la finance se remette au service de
l'humanité pour que l'argent redevienne
un moyen et non une fin pour que nous
devenions moteur d'une transition
écologique et sociale au service de
l'humain et de la nature le changement
est en marche et il part de l'individu
il part de chacun d'entre nous il
démarre par une prise de conscience et
ensuite il n'est plus possible de
l'arrêter parce que nous financier
sommes avant tout humain alors est-ce
que la finance est les moyens de changer
le monde
définitivement oui merci de m'avoir
écouté